The only way to not go crazy
trying to handle responsive images
is to set up an image pipeline
that makes it easy for
you to create multiple versions
of your images automatically.
And to do that you're going to
need the right software.
For your own sanity,
I want you to take a step back and
install Grunt, ImageOptim,
and ImageMagick.
Seriously, Grunt is super useful.
I use it all the time to
automate tasks for my projects.
ImageOptim and ImageMagick are also
awesome, because it makes it so
easy to convert images to different
sizes, formats, and compression levels.
You're going to want their help when
you start working on the project for
this course and in your future projects.
You'll find links in the instructor
notes for some how-to guides.
Once you've got everything installed,
check this box to continue.